good to have you with us thank you very
much for your time this morning so as we
just saw a little earlier there was a
protest this morning in rheems I imagine
there were going to be protests in other
parts of the country as well I mean how
did you see this playing out in the next
couple of days
well it's going to be tricky for
President Michael and more especially
for his prime minister Elizabeth Bond
because I mean so far they really went
out of their way to avoid what we've
seen yesterday that is to say the
triggering of article 49.3 which is a
very well known in France it's almost an
adjective in the French language to do a
40 a
49.3 I mean it's been done before it's
something that the constitution allows
um and indeed in the late 1980s Michelle
the former socialist prime minister
actually triggered it 28 times
um so this is not new but it means that
and lawmakers and their members of
parliaments feel completely cheated if
you'd like I mean the upper chamber
voted
um for an approved the pantry reform law
uh but there was no chance for the MPS
to actually do the same or to oppose it
and you know as a lot of things in
France uh there is likely to be
backlashing the streets uh the question
is how much
and I guess I mean you mentioned there
that it's a thing that's been used a
hundred times plenty of times uh
previously but I do Wonder there's a
political side of it and the fact that
it feels undemocratic to people but it's
also because it's the pension reforms
isn't it that's the thing that people
are really concerned about people in
France are very fortunate to have that
wonderful period in their later part of
their lives where they do have great
pensions and and many I guess would fear
that that is under Threat by these
reforms
yes they are very fortunate and they
probably don't realize how fortunate
they are because if they took some
distant uh distance and looked uh
elsewhere their European neighbors for
instance
um like in Germany or in Britain retire
at the age of 65 sometimes 66 so really
that reform which was watered down uh
for instance from the age of 65 to 64.
um is really would just put France
closer into line with its European
neighbors having said that
um pension reform is so very heated and
passionate Topic in France probably
because most most people here apart from
very very rich people
um rely on it rely on state pensions
there is no such thing as a private
schemes if you like individual private
schemes that you find in the UK or the
US so what you get after you're tired is
your income until uh the day you die so
um and and it is something that is
almost uh um uh you know something that
is emotional uh passionate and uh and
also that reform I must say was not was
not uh communicated uh to The Wider
public very well
um the real reason is that big deficits
are building up but instead of telling
the French that and to take a pragmatic
View and to talk about demographic
pressure
um the the uh the French government said
that the reform was a fairer reform
which is probably not the case uh not
fairer than the system before and so I
there was a clear communication failure
from the part of Elizabeth a governor of
Elizabeth Thorne government and indeed
there will be a no convenience vote
we'll see whether she he wins that in
Parliament because if she doesn't then
off she goes and her a government will
collapse meaning that President Michael
will have to appoint a new uh prime
minister and therefore a new government